There's some very
talented comedians that
are going to represent Detroit.
Alton "Boogie"
Williams, Mike Geeter,
Jeff Horste, and J Bell.
In Detroit, how long have you
guys have been doing comedy?
- 13 years.
This chose me.
I didn't-- you know, I
found a way to, you know,
make money doing it.
You know what I mean?
I was like, this
is actually an art.
This is actually-- you
know, because I didn't know.
I just knew what funny was.
I personally feel like
you can't teach funny.
I feel like either you
have it or you don't.
Do you guys feel the same?
You can't force it,
and you can't fake it.
Like, you can't
fake being funny.
[interposing voices]
Right here in Detroit.
That's not funny.
- Right.
Thick skin.
You've got to have it.
I can believe it.
this crowd slaps people.
I don't know if you heard
the history [inaudible]..
[inaudible] and stuff?
Yeah, man.
We'll see you in
the parking lot, cuz!
Yeah.
What about the comedy
scene here in Detroit?
I like a lot of
the independent.
There's a lot of
independent shows
that have been going lately.
Like, we had a recycling
center, an ice cream shop.
So I feel like there's never
ending amount of stage time
around here.
Especially if you're not judging
the room, then you can go up.
The people love comedy here.
Yes, they do.
Are the comedians close?
Are you guys a tight-knit group?
You want people to succeed.
Because if they succeed,
that puts Detroit
even further on the map.
Look, you're representing
Detroit comedy.
So you go out there,
and you do it.
You bring it.
You know what I'm saying?
100%, man.
it's the D.
Was there ever a moment where
you guys were like, you know,
this ain't-- this ain't it.
No.
Mm-mm.
This is-- this is all I have.
This is like, I ain't got--
I don't have no plan
B [inaudible] You
know them eggs in that basket?
They all in that
basket, brother.
If that basket break,
I'm going to be out there
washing cars or something.
Man, this is it.
This is it.
What I really
like and respect,
I mean, the love that you
obviously have for your city.
Oh, absolutely.
There's a sense of
urgency for you guys
to bring attention to Detroit.
You want to bring that light,
and you want it to shine.
And so I think you
should seize the moment.
Make the best of it, all right?
- Absolutely.
Do it.